a 2012 survey reported that 45% of
Americans believe in ghosts that's 8%
lower than those who believe in Hell and
20% higher than those who think God
decides the winner of the Super Bowl
ghosts in the paranormal have long been
a source of mystery spawning countless
television shows books and movies but it
wasn't until 2017 that their existence
would truly be put to the test and what
better entity to prove it then today I
want to examine one of the most bizarre
lawsuits in Hollywood history how it
came about and it's bloody conclusion
okay maybe not that bloody but in order
to understand where all this began we
must first travel back in time the year
is 1978 and Halloween is tearing it up
at the box office Jimmy Carter is
president and Simon is the most popular
toy in America but 78 is also the year
ed and Lorraine Warren a married team of
paranormal investigators decided to sell
the rights to their stories stories that
would later become the basis for such
films as The Amityville Horror Haunting
in Connecticut Annabelle and the
conjuring the author they gave the
rights to a man by the name of Gerald
brittle went on to make several novels
notably his 1980 work the demonologist
here in the table of contents you can
see the names of the chapters including
beyond Amityville Annabelle and the
Enfield voices which would become the
inspiration for the conjuring - and it
was around the release of the conjuring
- that brittles lawyers sent a
cease-and-desist to Warner Brothers
attempting to stop its release that's
when things got interesting Warner
Brothers argued that they don't need the
rights because the stories are based on
real historical events in other words
ghosts are real
in order for Warner Brothers to win the
case they would need to prove that the
events such as a demonic doll or
murderer switch actually happened as
Brittles attorney said Lorraine an ED
warns claim of what happened in their
Peron farmhouse case file which the
defendants freely and publicly admit
they're conjuring movie was based on
does not at all jive with the real
historical facts this is a pattern of
deceit that is part of a scheme that the
wardens have perpetuated for years there
are no historical facts of a witch ever
existing at the perón farmhouse a witch
hanging herself possession satanic
worship or child sacrifice the New
England skeptical society launched an
investigation into the warns they looked
over all the evidence and case files
concluding that the Warrens were quote
at best tellers of meaningless ghost
stories and at worst dangerous frauds
brittle thinking he had a strong case
did what anyone would do sue Warner
Brothers for nine hundred million
dollars the case seemed like a slam dunk
it was clear Warner Brothers was using
the Warne stories image flaunting it
even in the posters and fairing Lorraine
Warren and director James Wan to various
press junkets been a big fan of
Lorraine's for a while
now if read stories and seen you know
movies that were based on cases that
Lorraine investigated in an interview
explaining how she prepare for the role
of Lorraine Warren actress Vera Farmiga
said quote primarily my research relied
on the non-fiction book the demonologist
I felt a sense of terror every time I
cracked it open I never read the book in
the sanctity of my home in April of 2017
Warner Brothers attempted to dismiss the
lawsuit in court but failed as US
District Court Judge John Gibney jr.
said in his ruling the court declines
the party's invitation to wade into the
truth or falsity of the Warne's
paranormal escapades or to parse the
resulting similarities between the works
at this stage of the case this type of
analysis which bears on evidence
presented and factual determinations is
better suited for summary judgment or
trial so this case was going to trial
and if Warner Brothers was to win they
would have to prove with evidence and
factual determinations that indeed this
exists alas the studio that brought us
Battlefield Earth and this
what's not up to the challenge in a
somewhat anticlimactic finish in
December of 2017 brittle and Warner
Brothers settled for an undisclosed
amount but the story gets more bizarre
turns out brittle wasn't behind the case
it was a disgruntled producer by the
name of Tony De Rosa Grund in 2014 de
rosa grande a producer on the conjuring
began a string of lawsuits against
Warner claiming money owed and hurling
accusations such as money laundering and
overt racketeering acts when those suits
were dismissed
DeRosa grunt tracked down brittle and
ultimately bankrolled the whole thing in
court documents to Rosa Grund allegedly
threatened to fire brittles attorney if
they sent information he had not
approved and instructed brittle to
withhold information and documents from
their own attorneys when the attorneys
reminded to Rosic run that brittle was
their client not to rosa grande he
texted good then get Gerald to [ __ ]
pay you oh yeah he doesn't have a pot to
piss in these new revelations combined
with the drop lawsuit spurred the judge
to order a forensic examiner to comb
over all the documentation and look for
altered or deleted documents so like an
old episode of scooby-doo there's no
real ghost in this story just a man
hiding behind a mask attempting to get a
good scare and a couple million dollars
thanks for watching I was really hoping
they would prove ghosts exist because
that would be cool I know this video is
a bit different than my normal ones but
tell me what you think in the comments
do you want more videos like this and
don't forget to Like and subscribe